[Musique]
la rébellion des habitants de Shanghai
contre les mesures de confinement
prendre l'ampleur depuis la fin du mois
de mars les 25 millions d'habitants de
la ville sont confinés pour une durée
indéterminée ils sont de plus en plus
nombreux à s'opposer à la politique du
zéro covid et aux restrictions très
strictes mises en place par le
gouvernement chinois les habitants
critiquent particulièrement les
problèmes de livraison de nourriture des
manifestations ont eu lieu en bas de
certains immeubles des habitants crient
depuis leur fenêtres ou affichent des
messages de protestation dans la rue en
réaction la police a arrêté de nombreux
manifestants selon les autorités
seulement 10 personnes sont décédées du
covid-19 à Shanghai depuis le début du
confinement un chiffre remis en cause
sachant que les services de santé locaux
estiment que moins des deux tiers des
plus de 60 ans ont reçu deux doses de
vaccins et moins de 40% la troisième
dose toujours d'après le gouvernement
chinois moins de 5000 personnes sont
mortes du covid dans le pays depuis le
début de l'épidémie en 2019